what's going on guys we have an
embarrassment of riches when it comes to
comic book themed movie news it's out of
control just when you thought wow this
is huge
it gets even bigger and let's get right
into it leave an awesome panel to break
it down with first he is a comic book
writer extraordinaire torso Manhunter
that woman it's mark and Rico Aloha and
he is a writer for one of the best movie
news sites around slash film germaneness
ear playground Rebecca oh it's always
push back here so guys
big news dropped and then more big news
dropped are we at war is this official
or these shots fired this back and forth
it's crazy I don't know if it's shots
fired it's just like you said in
embarrassment Richie's and I think the
competition is great the more the more
Marvel raises the bar and then DC raises
the bar then we have things like 60c
shows on TV and six marvel movies it's
good for everybody I think as long as
the quality stays good
so Iron Man is going to be in Captain
America 3 and they're saying this is the
start of Marvel Civil War first I want
to take it back a step for people who
are not as familiar with the comics
civil war it pits so many of their
heroes basically at odds
the basic story was there was a disaster
super villains and a super villain super
hero team were fighting in this school
in Connecticut blew up and killed all
these kids so there was an outcry for a
superhuman Registration Act Tony Stark
was all for it Captain America having
been in World War 2 and see what happens
when people have to register themselves
and we're little maybe oh that's a
journey that's that's a slippery slope
their head-to-head against each other
and yes so basically this is taking
place after the Avengers age of Ultron
it's not going to be direct adaptation
of the complex civil war in the comic
book Civil War secret identities play a
big part Peter Parker reveals who he is
and it's big ass in the movies Robert
Downey jr. in the first movie so that's
not even an issue what we hear is that
Avengers age of Ultron is going to end
with destruction like you've never seen
before people buildings yeah and at the
end it's quite wonder if people will
complain about that like they did about
Madras hahaha but so that is going to do
to Tony Stark what it did in the comic
books make oh my god we need to do
something about this
Catherine Americans wouldn't disagree
there's
there's a Captain America 3 set up we
thought Avengers 3 was going to be
Thanos now we know that no he's going to
pull back Plus Avengers 3 is probably
gonna be called recasting every third is
going to be a Captain America is going
to take a movie off where it's going to
be Iron Man and these new character
strange we have Sandman is if Chris
Evans contract is up and he's no longer
captain or he is Bucky going do well he
has one more movie ever set Captain
America through yeah Chris Evans has
vengers 3 on Captain America 3 he's
contracted for a number of movies not
specific movies right
they might just pull a bunch of these
guys to save them for the big Guardians
mega you saw wait that's not rumor so
when they announced it down he's gonna
be here it was almost like this big
piece of the puzzle fit oh my god
everything clicked it was one of those
moments I just had a cash register going
to G well that too look at me at the end
of a thought it's all I was especially
because they were gonna I'm sorry to
drop its that Batman vs Superman opens
in March that year and may that yours
Iron Man vs. Captain America they were
gonna open on the same day Marvel and DC
go to have their vs. movies yeah with
their two biggest stars and how do you
see a spider-man coming into the oh man
I don't know if he's going to I mean
like I said the rumor is yeah that
they're talking about it it's great
press it's great headlines
it would require I think what Billy a
Middle East where is he and Sony figure
out a way to make that work for both of
ya it's really it's really two
corporations that we're talking about
corporations that's what it's all about
and I think it would be great for Sony
to get some goodwill with the fans after
that they're not sure what to do amazing
spider-man 3 might not be till 2018 at
that point we'll have seen so many other
movies is he going to be as cool I think
if you put him into Avengers 3 if you
put him into Civil War if Peter Parker
fills that role filled in the comic
books it would be huge but again money
alright so we were having you guys in
just to talk about Marvel Civil War then
BAM this DC slate of movies dropped
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
Suicide Squad Wonder Woman and Justice
League part 1 the flash and Aquaman
Shazam and Justice League part 2 and
then cyborg and Green Lantern
and a Batman and a Superman movie that
are still yet to be dated biggest
surprise on this slate my big surprise
is that we have Batman and Superman and
three movies where they don't star and
so we know we're going to see Batman
spin-off with Ben Affleck we're going to
see a man feel - we'll call it we don't
know when and actors how that's going to
fit in because those characters as
important and great as the flash and
Green Lantern are those are the
a-listers but that you know what you
just saying that makes me think that DC
and Warner Brothers are being very smart
because Superman and Batman are the
marquee characters by not putting them
in there it allows them to showcase get
people to talk about these because you
did put the bedroom and a show there
people will be talking about that oh
yeah that is the headline and that's the
main event then we have the under crowd
man now this is the main event and then
it's like oh yeah because that will
generate interest no that's a great
great plan so dawn of Justice is pretty
much establishing the Justice League and
then do you have any idea what we can
expect in Justice League
part one I'm assuming they're going to
build the dark side if Marvel is going
to push fan o's off to the side for a
while that would make the most sense to
seize that opportunity to have the big
Darth Vader of the DC Universe go
go cosmic because the Marvel characters
we relate to because they could be us DC
characters are like a pantheon of Greek
gods yeah they're these bigger than life
characters so having a big cosmic
adventure
brought to earth I think could be really
really good same year as Justice League
part one comes out you're gonna have the
Wonder Woman film which is pretty cool
you're gonna have a female-driven
superhero film also announced in 2020
cyborg um the first super o fill in a
long time led by a person of color we
were talking about Marvel and DC the
budding of the head yeah you know
everybody been giving Marvel a lot of
crap about not having a black widow
movie I miss more of a movie Captain
Marvel and there it is a DC comes in and
undercuts them and announces they're a
big female superhero man but they also
have a character in Wonder Woman way
more iconic they are to have a cast
yeah people all over the globe Wonder
Woman is because the name recognition
value there is great and they just did a
study that like 47 percent of the comic
readers are women so they need to serve
this audience and I'm glad to see it in
cyborg I can't believe it during a
sidebar movie a black teenage superhero
it's about damn time
just kind of pulling back and looking at
both their strategies Marvel kind of
peace meals their information they do it
in phases okay and DC is like BAM big
picture what happens if something
doesn't go right
well that's happen if you have you lay
an egg in there that's true for both of
those companies Marvel Marvel releases
to the public phases more I'm sure in
the Marvel offices I'm sure Kevin has a
chart going through 2030 of what is
going to have yeah so but the only guys
but DC at this point because they are in
Marvel's shadow cinematically so much
they need to come out and say this is
what we're doing they need to make that
big announcement this is all subject to
change too if in the Justice League
movie if you know a character becomes
super popular yeah they're going to
delft ass track that as well this is
this is this is a template from which to
depart this is best-case scenario but
there's all sorts of places where this
can move there's going to be a bad movie
in there I'll tell you right now there's
going to be one or two but if they have
these other movies planned and if they
have goodwill because of Batman or
Superman I mean we're still going to
show up one last piece of big news that
just dropped this week our good friend
Mark and Draco you're going to be
writing a new comic book for DC I'm
going to be writing coming out in
December Wonder Woman 77 based on the
Lynda Carter a cartoon very cool show
mark that is so cool don't forget us
when you are writing the Wonder Woman 77
major motion picture guys fantastic
stuff and there's so much more to break
down so many cool things so much to
argue about and in fact we're gonna do
it on screen junkies movie fights check
out the next episode right here this
Sunday or subscribe on iTunes and listen
to it while you're on your way to work
or at the gym screen junkies movie
fights it's awesome good times guys what
do you think about the slate of movies
and Marvel Civil War and all that news
sense of it in the comments below the
most awesome comments we're gonna send
you a screen junkies t-shirt again I
want to thank these awesome guys mark
and Draco Germain Lussier
I want to thank you for watching I'm how
rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye
I don't know if you guys are married or
not when you get married the highlight
becomes sitting down and watching
television with you why binge watching
yeah the key to us liking the show is to
get married yes I really think it
changes everything